[Musique]
c'est une céline radieuse en pleine
possession de ses moyens qui est apparu
mercredi soir sur la scène du centre
vidéotron de québec robe rouge payet tes
cheveux courts corps découpé l'artiste
est dans une forme resplendissante
est ce que vous réalisez que vous faites
partie de la première mondiale de la
tournée courage c'est sur une vaste
scène dans un décor chic et épuré que la
reine de la soirée entourée de ses
musiciens et choristes a livré son tout
premier spectacle produit sans son
complice de toujours
rené angélil et les plus belles et les
plus en forme que jamais dans le coeur
bravo merci grand artiste de faire et
elle a retrouvé le sa joie de vivre qui
s'écoule en garde jean mermoz le sait un
jour le 15 janvier j'amène ma vie elle
est merveilleux c'est vraiment bien
j'adore sa nouvelle coupe de cheveux ça
que je vous dis
l'artiste est solide et envoie à
l'interpréter 29 chansons de son vaste
répertoire dont quelques-unes de son
nouvel album qui sortira en novembre
si céline et parmi la liste des
personnalités les mieux habillées en
elle ne perdra pas sa place avec ses
costumes de scène et bel équilibre entre
classes et excentricités céline sera de
retour sur la scène du centre vidéotron
de québec vendredi et samedi et
poursuivra sa tournée vers montréal et
ottawa
ici claudia genel radio canada québec
[Applaudissements]